I think I'd like to like to start with
trying to get a distribution in the room
so I know who I have to fight here how
many data scientists do we have in the
room okay most okay we're winning here
we're winning here data engineers
machine learning engineers okay there's
a few learn soldiers and someone who has
to do the terrible job of DevOps model
ops okay this one's for you so has
anyone here I think the last question
that I'd like to know is has anyone
heard about kid row before this talk
some people okay that's pretty cool so
brief introduction about me I am a
product manager at quantum black I'll be
explaining a bit more about what the
company does in a moment because it
explains why kids are exists I'm there
anything that I manage to do now I'm
kidding I'm beyond being part of an
amazing team of quantum block is open
sourcing it open sourcing something from
a consultancy is a nightmare guys but it
had to happen and I'll explain a bit
more at the end of the presentation
about what that what that meant I have a
background in data engineering and data
product management so I could have
actually been a user of Kedra as opposed
to being the Builder on it so at least I
come with it with that level of empathy
and I always joke that I'm 65%
south-african you can ask me at the
after party what that means um so I
should actually explain a bit more about
like quantum black and like why we
actually think about caterers so quantum
black was an advanced analytics company
that was acquired by McKinsey about four
years ago they say it was born out of
Formula one where our co-founders used
to do kind of like high performance
racecar analytics and eventually went on
to saying hey how about we apply these
principles to businesses so we required
we're kind of like the black ops in the
firm in McKinsey and our job is
basically to make sure that we put code
into production and we deliver business
value when we do that I sit within
quantum black labs which is technically
our product engineering where we
basically hole
little tools that help our teams do that
so this isn't introduced as the kidron
story but I'm gonna start off with a few
definitions so that we're all on the
same page it's when I talk about a data
pipeline I'm talking about the process
of taking data from somewhere doing
something to it and putting it somewhere
else so something to it could be a
machine learning pipeline it could just
be an extract an ETL process as well I
also will refer to that when I talk
about production writing code I'm saying
that your code is going to be
reproducible because many people are
gonna try run it or work with it with
you we also talked about it being
modular so that it's broken down into
small compostable units and then it's
also well documented so that other
people can understand it and then the
roles were then quantum black which I'll
keep referring to in our worlds I don't
know because these roles are very new
and upcoming in our world the data
engineer is a person who works in any
data environment and then basically
helps construct the massive table so
you'd go through your different we have
what we call our data engineering
Convention when you move from the raw
layer all the way to primary eight to
the model input table and that is that
person that does that our data
scientists are basically PhD masters
people that focus on actually applying
like modeling techniques to the master
table and then our machine learning
engineer is an hour in our world and our
definition is the person who basically
says okay we've got a data science model
we now need to put it back into whatever
kinds infrastructure exists so why does
Cantor actually exist we have larger
teams when we actually go out on our
client engagement so you're typically
working upwards of four people on the
same codebase sometimes up to 10 people
on the same codebase and what typically
happens is if if it's just me working on
my own project yeah I know how I how I
usually do things on my project but if
there are ten people that think that it
makes it really challenging to
collaborate with each other when you do
that clean code is also expected from us
because our measure of success is not
necessarily just handing over codebase
and running away
our coat our measure of success is
actually being able to work with
companies that can maintain their data
pipeline when we go that is success for
us so it's this whole thing of the code
is clean because you need to understand
it because a data pipeline is not static
when it's delivered it's still fluid and
you might need to modify it in the
future so we have high standards for
that we also don't have time to refactor
bad code badly structured code there's
time to the obviously code optimization
when you put them out onto production
but thinking through that whole process
of restructuring backlog we don't have
time for that and then also we come at
it with this level of empathy so
everyone keeps saying I think Mariana
and the previous session mentioned the
data scientists should learn like kind
of like these software engineering
principles but we approach it with that
empathy of you have a workflow you have
a certain level of expertise late--
bring everyone to a higher bar together
and that's actually why care dresses so
if you put the install kit robe if you
want to try it now
you actually have access to the tool we
match the open source and in June
earlier on this year and I'm gonna let
some of the kids or users in the next
video
introduce what it does and if sound
works we'll be happy or no let's see
should I try again yes
hi I'm Philip and six months ago this
was me mine wasn't vegetable or softness
on the step
Philips approach with and structure
making it challenging to collaborate so
that's what Catalina - so for us the
early really useful data science code is
production level code and the really
exciting thing about Carowinds helps you
structure your data pipeline which is
software engineering principles meaning
your code is production ready from the
get-go so you can spend more time
focusing on building your data pipelines
kidrauhl so standardizes the way your
team collaborating it easier to
transition from development to
production rates large chunks of code
into small modular units that can be
easily tested which lean sets sorry guys
which means it's easy to identify errors
in your data pipeline hey my analogy the
cancer project template is really easy
to use it looks great and it
standardizes everything which means
collaborators aren't wasting any time
figuring out how I've set up my
analytics project so for him it's all
about data abstraction yes sure it is I
like how keto helps me manage saving and
loading of data so I don't have to worry
about their disability oh my go to
different environments sometimes this
means even here and the configuration
management keeps credentials out of my
codebase the development distress driven
the food quality is monitored I know my
data pipeline is robust and production
and packaging allows us to easily
produce white document a code and ship
it to the doctor plus it's open source
which is a first for quantum black and
Mackenzie if you take away anything from
this video then it's the caterer makes
it easy to deploy machine learning
models and production because it applies
software engineering principles to data
science and data engineering code that
anyone can understand so that was
actually made when we're open sourcing
of those of all people that exist to the
quantum black it took me ten tries to
try and four magnets for it and I almost
wore the same Jersey today I'm glad I
didn't so Kendra we open-source it it's
maintained by the quantum black teams we
kind of think of it as the bridge
between machine learning and software
engineering it helps you build data
pipelines that are consistent they're
versions they reproducible and they're
scalable the five concepts I'm going to
focus on today are going to be how we
think about a project template who here
is actually familiar with cookie cutter
data science you guys are good so you'll
you'll you'll quickly pick this one up
and understand it we're gonna talk about
how we think about configuration how we
manage our data catalog as well you can
think of it as basically a series of
data connectors that can connect to any
type of data source that you need for
your machine learning workflow we're
gonna talk about our nodes which are our
way of referring to our tasks so coke
tasks in pipeline and framework
terminology I mean we're going to talk
about how we construct our pipeline as
well I will take you through an example
so you'll see all these components come
together so project template and this
basically falls in line with the whole
thing of the cookie cutter data science
is this whole way of having basically a
standard way that everyone interacts
with an analytics project it means that
you're not spending time sitting down
with someone and explaining to them
where you've located all your code and
like where things should sit because
everyone knows that this is the way that
the project is structured so
our project template also supports
States for documentation so if you're
using Google Docs strings in your
functions things Docs will pick that up
so your code is like documented for you
we do support pipe sets as well in the
template as well as standard like pipes
and logging as well so those elements of
like good practice that you should have
for your data pipelines are basically
embedded in it it's also modifiable so
since we've released
Kedra we've actually found interesting
ways that people have been modifying
this template themselves so obviously
they don't like our opinion in some ways
and they've actually modifying the
template to do even more things than
they want we generally think of it as
like the best starting place for you
because it's basically built with I
think now over 90 major client
engagement best practice like built into
this template I'm gonna specifically
dial into configuration though and we
think of configuration as your way to
move from prototype to production with
ease it's this whole belief that the
same code that you write because it
doesn't have any hard-coded variables in
that can easily be translated when you
move it so we support configuration for
logging so you might have different ways
of logging for development versus in
production we also support it for what
we call our data catalog which I'll be
taking you through next
so now hard-coded file pots will be
loaded located in your code base and
then also for primitives as well the
parameters one is really useful because
for the first time you basically or if I
think if anyone is ever going to come
and look at your work they know that all
your parameters are located in like one
place so it's easy to refer they don't
have to basically like dig through your
code base to try and find like which
functions match which parameters we
talked about a data catalog which is our
data abstraction it's completely
extensible and available via a code API
or gamal API it basically is our series
of data connectors we support obviously
you see like many different formats
currently and the list is actually
currently growing because we find in
different different ways that people are
actually different requirements that
people have for being able
to connect to different data sources
currently supported storage layers
include s3 also at AWS s3 and then is
your blob storage on some of the data
sets as well but our abstract dataset
class is really and like really really
easy to extend when you come down to it
it's like I think it's about like 15
lines of code that you basically just
need to extend for whatever data can or
data class that you have that we don't
necessarily support in Cairo and then
when you're using the bulletin functions
as well for referencing pandas tables
and SPARC tables they use the same load
and save arguments so you're not
learning a new API when you use them we
also do support data versioning every
single time your data set is saved and
in the latest version of header which
was released yesterday we're actually
starting to tie the data versioning to
your code so we'll be able to one day
automatically reproduce kids or runs or
pipeline runs the next concept that I'm
going to be addressing is obviously how
we think about our tasks in control and
tasks our Python functions or PI spark
functions depending on what you write
that's it when we say we're referring to
a node it's basically this whole
component over here where we've got an
input of some sort we've got a Python
function that requires this input and
then we've got an output that comes from
it when we think of our pipeline it's
basically stitching together there's
different nodes to construct it and
you'll actually see it in the code
syntax how easy this is
because you do that you basically get
what we call cheder of is another kid or
plugin out of the box
based on your code a lovely way of being
able to communicate to your business
stakeholders why your machine learning
model is not ready on week one because
you have a lot of data cleaning and
feature engineering to actually complete
that's actually how our teams use it to
basically say hey we're doing so much
work before we can even look at the data
science part of our workflow and here's
actually how we get we get through it
kyndra's is also open sourced in terms
of being able to package
Kedra we do also support obviously kid
which is your way of being able to
package your Hendra project in the
docker container interesting ways that
our teams have been able to scale with
it is obviously
Kedra kid or docker and cuban Eddie's as
a way of like orchestrating those
different containers and then if you
really need to transition to something
like air flow we also do provide that
flexibility for you to do that the
reason why you choose to start in
hedgerow is because it's much easier to
get started in kid row than it is in air
flow so in terms of being able to I
guess bring everyone up to a level where
they can eventually move their code to
air flow Kedra definitely helps with
that so the example I'm gonna actually
give you today actually takes you into
the year 2164 whatever reason we do not
have algorithms that write algorithms
and your job is to produce a price
prediction problem to understand how
much does it cost to fly what factors
influence like flying to the moon and
back because there are thousands of
Space Shuttle companies out there so you
can tell we had a lot of fun writing
this tutorial it's actually in our dots
and we also do support the full code
base in header examples as well so I'm
gonna do you use modification of this
I'm not gonna focus on the price
prediction component of it I'll just
focus on the pre-processing pipeline
that produces the master table as a way
of like really simplifying it so you can
see how all of these kids are concepts
fit together the first thing I'm going
to do though is actually sure you header
this so you actually understand how this
is a very basic pipeline we had three
input tables a company's table which
basically had all the company company
information we had the shuttle's
information so each company has multiple
shuttles also as an input there and then
we also have customer reviews from that
information so you can see over here
shuttles companies reviews the shuttles
table had to go undergo some
pre-processing and so did the company's
table we had the output tables coming
out as pre per size shuttles pre-process
companies and
together with reviews they were fed into
the master table so the first thing
you're gonna run is kid renew so you pip
install kid row hopefully in some sort
of like virtual environment because we
also believe in good practice for pipes
and package dependency management so
kendra near basically generates the
imperfect Simplot like i said this thing
is completely extensible based on like
whatever you need on your project so if
you find you don't need all of those
files and folders delete them like
you're you ready to go the next thing
you're gonna do is now set up your data
catalog so for this very very basic
example we have access to to CSV data
sets and one excel data set as well when
we're using the Amelie API for the data
catalog you can actually see how we
indicate the different data sets this is
basically becoming our data registry
where we can say here is the type of
data set here are many different
parameters or may be arguments that need
to actually load that data and sometimes
even save the data as well and where
it's located if you do use different
notebooks
we encourage using them for exploratory
analysis only so this whole thing I've
being able to still support I think what
they're good at which is helping you
explore the data and I think produce
your initial version of your pipeline
our data scientists do work like that
but they move out of Dupin a notebook
into Python script so that they can
obviously construct their data pipeline
so in this case your workflow with Kedra
looks at reloading kendra to reload
essentially our killer context and then
you basically can access those data sets
with context like catalog got load which
in 15.2 is now just catalog load and you
basically have access to all of those
data sets culled from configuration so
this whole thing of your workflow with
Kedra does not have file pots in it does
not have large chunks of code which
basically load those data sets for you
because that's specified in
configuration for you
when we talk about obviously a kid
remote we're talking about a Python
function so here is an example of a
Python function used to actually process
the shuttle stable you're not
additionally we do have dog strings in
there so this is whole thing I'd be able
to produce well-documented code so if
you just indicate that in your Python
script you're ready to go when we
construct a Kandra pipeline this is
actually what our syntax looks like for
that pipeline I'm gonna break it down
for you so here's actually how we define
our pipeline here is a note for
pre-processing on the shuttle's table so
you note pre-process shuttle's was the
actual Python function the input table
was that shuttle's table that we defined
in our data catalog and the output table
was pre-processed shuttle's I'll be
talking about be precise shuttles pre
poisonous companies in the second
example and the master table in the in
the last one so over here we've got new
process companies as the next Python
function that we made its input table
companies its output table pre-processed
companies the nerd syntax also supports
multiple inputs and multiple outputs as
well and in this case we need the
multiple inputs to join the three tables
together so create master table was the
Python function that joined everything
together and the output of it was the
master table those output tables were
not actually defined in our data catalog
and what that means to kid row is that
those objects those data sets are paused
in memory and so they need it if I
actually needed to save them I'd
actually have to list them as entries in
the data catalog and tell kids or where
they should be saved
um really useful for debugging if you do
work like this but otherwise for I think
when you move later on in your
development process when you share of
your data pipeline it's just easier to
just remove them for the data catalog
and use the memory data set to actually
do that and all you need to do is just
delete them and they disappeared we
meant execute care to run and you will
see that we use obviously Python logging
everything is saved in your logs folder
so that you have access to it later
so this is the remnant successful
execution we do have access to them head
rivers once again where you visualize
your pipeline and then many different
ways of being able to package your work
you can build dogs you can build the
requirements that you need for your
workflow so you can hand over
effectively you can actually package
your kid reject as or kids or pipeline
rather as an egg or wheel for deployment
you can do contra docker build which
will build the docker image of your kid
or workflow and then also you can cut
your airflow crate to create the airflow
dag that you need in your air flow
workflow so overall our status to date
is that we were use reuse no more on 90
advanced analytics projects within the
firm so that's each company may need
different industries is using hetro we
open source in June 2019 primarily
because our clients wants to be able to
use it after we left so might have a
great time when they're using it with
their data scientists and we're using it
without date of the data scientists and
then when we left they would be like
wait
but upgrades support and we're like whoa
whoa open source and we fix that issue
so that's basically where we see like
obviously building a community it
becomes like really important but that's
a component we're watching it grow
organically but that's something that is
happening now and then we're also
looking into some of the stuff on
performance scaling for kid rows so
making it easier to when the kid or
pipeline is in production to basically
get performance benefits from it so I
don't if you guys are familiar with an
open source project called deaths we
will be looking at the desk integration
and there'll be a new way to deploy kids
or pipelines to the kid or a P i if you
do want to access like resources for kid
row care to read the dots we spent a ton
of time on our documentation it's there
are two tutorials in there a hello world
iris dataset example but you can have
access to your and then also the longer
form space lights tutorial that I was
just taking you through we're up on
github as well so that mean
quantum black labs / cadra you'll find
us there as mentioned the project is
maintained by us so you will see me like
lurking around responding to like your
issues when your pro requests we have
something called a wizard every week so
it's a team of eight that maintain Kedra
and our wizard is basically like staffed
to basically handle like all concerns
that you have and then if you do post
questions and Stack Overflow and tag
them with hedgerow not that anyone has
yet we will be able to find them I think
one of the reasons why we are watching
Stack Overflow is because we still speak
on our internal slack about canter and
I'm trying to get our guys to move
outward so that this information is
shared across then we don't have
information loss and that leaves us down
to questions
thank you very much ooh lots of
questions all right let's see hi thank
you for your talk just a very quick
question you were mentioning that Google
Cloud integration will be available soon
can you give any update on how that will
happen sure so we actually do have a
pull request at least for the CSV data
set on Google cloud platform okay
there's two ways to look at it if you
need to use Cutrone as of this moment
all of our s three data sets can
basically support the GCP you just need
to change one parameter and then you're
only using like the read and write
binary from Google cloud platform that's
like if you need to use it like that
you're burning like me to use it now but
as for being able to move the pull
request through we just have an external
contributor raise the CSV TCP data set
and it's on the backlog I think for the
next two sprints actually actually
complete the catalog of TCP data sets so
maybe another two weeks we'll have like
the full the full suite including Google
Play bigquery as well so in the example
that you showed this structure of the
project
I assume this is so committed into
source version control and I see the the
CSV C are in a folder so I understand
this an example how does it work with
larger data sets that are maybe in cloud
storage and I'm just curious how it
would work with some real data
definitely select Dana folder in my
project template is actually getting
norwich so this whole thing I'm not
committing data is good practice don't
do it don't do it how does it actually
work so the data remember if we have a
look at the data catalog on the way that
it's actually structured I'm just gonna
go back might be easier to just click
here
let's die you can connect to any data
source wherever it's located so it
doesn't necessarily need to actually sit
relative to the project for you to be
able to use it so where you specify the
file path like basically Kidder will
read it from there that's why we
consider the data catalog is like a
connector to it but yeah in terms of
like committing or using data relative
to your folder structure that doesn't
work so that's actually why we can
support like big data pipelines as well
within Kedra because it's it doesn't
usually look like this this is like a
very basic very very basic example so
you can connect to different cloud
storage there's and some teams and now
building connectors for Delta Lake they
just need to now write tests for it so
that we can actually put it back into
our contrib there and that's why
actually why they've also been packing
around would like TCP so you can just
connect wherever you need where but your
data is located hi thank you very much
one one question about the possibilities
for data line eight so this is a
something that many people want to do
like in many pieces of hardware and it's
a big problem so what can Gator do for
discovering data lineage from Ament data
set to all the intermediate states
question
so in terms of dania data lineage like
there's two ways to look at it kendra
vis already supports an ability for you
to just see the data workflow so you
would have seen it from where the
sources of data were coming from to what
was the final output in the end or the
final model that you out you had at the
end so you can really see that layer in
kid rivers and obviously our data
engineers will work according to a
structure convention which you can read
about in our Doc's like how they
structure that workflow so it's all
there but we want to actually take it a
step further so there's always been talk
about how we even enable a common level
lineage in our data sets we haven't
quite cracked that model yet but at
least for now you have a vision of where
the data sets land up
hi-yah thanks for the talk so you were
saying you look into tasks integration
so currently kid Rodin brings its own
scheduler does it also support whole
execution good question sir Kendra does
not support its own scheduler currently
so we rely obviously on tools like
airflow or whatever you want to use to
do that we do a parallel execution
though so you do have choice with
integer for sequential runner or a
parlor runner what we will do what our
desk integration prototype actually
looks like is creating a desk runner and
then subsequent like desk data sets for
you to be able to take everything into
dusk and and run it accordingly like
that so that's actually how that
workflow would look more questions all
thanks for showing us these convenient
features in Cairo one question that are
relating to a video where you've shown
basically let's pretend I'm a data
scientist who tends to write rather code
how does kettle prevent me from doing
that can you maybe give some examples
rabbit curd lasagna coat spaghetti code
so for this one how would you it prevent
you so I think the first thing is we do
abstract a lot of like the software
engineering concepts as well so that you
don't necessarily need to think about
how I'm going to implement these things
on your own the only way I would
recommend this is I don't know following
actually the basic tutorial will
actually take you through that complete
workflow of I set up my project template
I have to connect my data sources
wherever they're located I have a
Jupiter notebook workflow which is what
I was previously using before but we
show you how to just tweak it a little
bit so that your ad betting in getting
better code we even have a way to export
your code from you to put in notebooks
as kid Roo
convert to actually export your code
into essentially the Python script but
this is done on the caveat that you
still at least have knowledge of I need
to be writing Python functions so
modular code as well because otherwise
then Kendra doesn't really fit for your
workflow thank you for your talk I
missed something about version 2 models
instead yeah well available it's
available kind of so the reason why we
do support model versioning now is
because we look at models as data sets
so dataset data set versioning
essentially means in Cairo every single
time my pipeline is run I will be able
to save a version of it with a timestamp
that is linked to it we obviously don't
do what we call them experiment tracking
which is where we look at okay how do we
look at how this model is like evolved
over time and actually be able to have a
way of comparing it we rely on another
internal tool it's called performance
data there's a medium blog about it
where they have basically built on top
of ml flow to make that functionality
like fleshed out for our users but where
we will be taking the model version in
two is I think it's probably going to be
in release like fifteen point three or
sixteen where we actually have now tied
what we call our data versioning to code
so that it's not as useless as it
currently is with how we think of that
about catalogs it's very similar to the
intake projects have you compared the
two and what are the pros and cons I'm
certain take I think in take is our you
can think of it as our feature
competitor on data abstraction it's a
project by anaconda but you guys should
check out because it's also a really
cool thing
they have a GUI as well for helping you
load data sets but they obviously do use
the em all if you guys layer as well we
do both loading and saving of data which
intake does not do so that would be the
I think the primary differentiating
factor so I cut a lot Campbell's both
they just handle the loading of the data
they also no support like obviously the
pipeline framework in their structure
and then also the project template too
so you'd have to rely on other tools to
get that so what's wrong here yeah and I
saw their hands right through for you
I'm sure you can just approach yeah tool
and a scary person yeah you guys can
find me I'm here okay again thanks for
the presentation I think it's a really
cool tool it serves many purposes right
I mean it starts from templating and
then defining the data catalog releasing
your model etc now an open source
there's many tools serving the same
purpose like for example you could just
use plain cookie cutter at the beginning
or you could use poetry for some parts
of your workflow does it make sense to
use your tool for only one particular
purpose and use other tools for the rest
or is it all the way in or not at all
you can choose so the way that Kanter is
actually structured is that you can
choose to use like certain components of
it you're not basically restricted going
project template in and then I have to
like use everything some ways that the
teams have used it for instance project
template they like the data abstraction
they're running a Kafka pipeline and
they basically make use of their
functionality they'd like that so it's
not necessarily like you have to like
buy in completely it says you can use
like certain components of it and the
libraries for the pipeline and the data
catalog at least the api's are very
stable
it's like they're very minimal changes
between them I'm trying to think of also
another reason why you would choose to
use it oh this is actually related to
how the cool ways we've seen that people
in the open-source community use it so
we've historically used Kevlar obviously
to solve a machine learning use case it
was basically a business need and you're
basically solving they would be
output whether it's its informations
being push their database or it's
serving some sort of front-end when I
was release we started seeing weird
occurrences of people not solving these
cases with it but below they want we
call reusable pipelines so basically
making what we call doing 80% of their
machine learning workflow linking it to
certain data sets that they would need
as intermediate intermediate features
and then telling us that hey we keep
rewriting this code over and over again
because they cookie-cutter users and now
here's a way for us to actually
structure about workflow but whenever we
approach a new data set that this needs
to be used on we obviously need to
change the input somewhere and Candra
basically has done 80% of the work
because the code is there we just need
to make slight tweaks to make it work so
this whole thing of I think we're
finding interesting ways that it's been
used where reusable pipelines I think
for one has been quite interesting to
see things again and yeah it's in thing
yeah
[Applause]